noticias económicas en france 24 con
jorge hurtado jorge los saludo
nuevamente indudablemente el tema de hoy
es evergrande que cumplió su plazo o se
le cumplió más bien el plazo con uno de
los tenedores de bonos sin embargo logró
renegociar en qué va este tema así es la
compañía prometió que asumirá el pago de
los intereses que vencen este 23 de
septiembre pero no aclaró se incluyen
los 83.5 millones de dólares en total
pero lo que más preocupa es su absoluta
deuda que esté más de 300 mil millones
de dólares lo mismo que el producto
interno bruto de un país como chile y el
efecto que pueda generar sobre el
mercado financiero global la unidad de
autos eléctricos del grupo ever brand no
pagó salarios y se retrasó en el pago de
varios proveedores lo que evidencia que
la deuda tiene un impacto mayor según
fuentes cercanas a esa empresa el diario
the wall street journal se atreve
incluso a decir que beijing ya le pidió
a los gobiernos locales que se preparen
para una posible debacle del grupo
inmobiliario que no sólo es inmobiliario
tiene inversiones en autos eléctricos
alimentos y hasta en uno de los equipos
de fútbol más grandes del país esta
tarde algunos compradores de inmuebles
se presentaron en shenzhen sede de la
empresa para reclamar el dinero de sus
inversiones el programa mantiene casi
1000 proyectos activos de los cuales
ahora se desconoce su futuro el temor
más grande es que la quiebra de esta
empresa pueda desestabilizar el sistema
financiero de china y desencadenar una
reacción en cadena a nivel global sin
embargo ángela de esta teoría mantiene
reacciones encontradas escuchamos
china tiene una economía enorme aunque
ver gran tiene un gran volumen económico
no es suficiente para provocar una
crisis financiera es imposible tal vez
sea cuando una pequeña piedra cae en un
gran lago y deja una honda se calmará
pronto
después
cambiando de tema han sido días
difíciles en argentina para el gobierno
de alberto fernández pero hoy se anunció
que bajó la tasa de desempleo bueno
según el instituto nacional de
estadística descenso la tasa de
desempleo bajó en el segundo trimestre
de este año al 9,6 por ciento su nivel
más bajo desde finales de 2019 pese a
esto persisten los problemas laborales
que se agudizaron con la pandemia del
coronavirus las autoridades informaron
que la tasa de desempleo del segundo
trimestre estuvo 06 puntos porcentuales
por debajo de la primera del primer
trimestre y 3,5 puntos debajo del mismo
período del 2020 durante la pandemia
el dato desocupado bajó en el segundo
trimestre a un millón 273 mil personas
la flexibilización de las medidas de
confinamiento hizo crecer a la población
económicamente activa al 45,9 por ciento
pasando de 11 millones en el segundo
trimestre de 2020 a 13,2 millones en el
mismo período de este año
jorge más desencuentros entre beijing y
taipei pero ahora por lo económico así
es recientemente china se opuso
categóricamente a que taiwán se pueda
incorporar al acuerdo progresivo e
integral de asociación transpacífico
este es uno de los pactos comerciales
más grandes del mundo taipei pidió
unirse una semana después de beijing lo
que provocó una protesta del gobierno
chino la polémica está ángel en que en
el 2001 taiwán accedió como miembro de
la organización mundial de comercio bajo
el nombre de china taipei ahora taiwán
quiere hacer lo mismo pero china
protestó aduciendo que se opone a que
cualquier país realice tratados o
negocios con esa región el acuerdo
engloba a 11 países entre ellos japón
méjico perú chile australia y nueva
zelanda este acuerdo representa el 13
por ciento del volumen mundial del
comercio y es momento de revisar los
indicadores de la jornada por favor
bueno sin duda las promesas de pago
deberán calmó los nervios en las bolsas
mundiales 'wall street' por ejemplo
cerró en positivo un día después de la
reunión de la fed y en américa latina la
bolsa cerraron en relativa calma excepto
en brasil- angela donde decenas de
manifestantes ocuparon por una hora la
bolsa de sao paulo en protesta por el
alza de precios y el desempleo en ese
país
y finalmente la cifra del día bueno la
cifra del día es 210 mil millones de
dólares eso costará a la escasez de
chips al sector de automóvil y se
producirán 77 millones de vehículos
menos en 2021 la crisis de chip se
arrancó con la pandemia cuando los
fabricantes suspendieron su producción
durante semanas al tiempo que la demanda
de otros sectores que requieren también
de chips creció ahora que el sector
automotriz volvió a realizar pedidos los
fabricantes de chips no han podido
responder a esta gran demanda
jorge gracias y ustedes decidan con
nosotros en france 24 buenas noches
[Música]